[Music]
the 2016 election has been eye-opening
for me personally and for a lot there's
been a lot of personal reflection around
what does it mean to be involved for a
lot of people I think and I hope that we
take president Trump's victory as a
warning of what disengagement can cost
us and I think our leaders have failed
to lead on a lot of different dimensions
I think government has lost a productive
culture of public service that makes it
hard to participate it makes it hard to
understand the value of engaging in
politics our first associations where
the word politician is like corruption
dishonesty right when public service
should be about our highest ideals it
should be about our collective success
it should be about what is best and most
ambitious for a group of people working
together to around a shared sense of
purpose and so I think it's people wake
up to wait a second how is this possible
here I think there is both there's a
couple of things that work there one is
a you know as the country becomes more
urban and urban centers are decidedly
more liberal we have a sense that the
country is more much more liberal than
it actually is turns out it's a really
big country turns out there are a lot of
people that still don't live in cities
so it turns out there are a lot of sort
of frustrated people who live in cities
who believed in Obama because of the
promises he made about changing the
system that Trump was a much more
natural successor to than president than
Secretary Clinton was and so I think the
concept of someone who is frustrated and
anxious seeing President Obama failed to
largely change the culture of politics
see Trump as the bolts for the china
shop right and there's a pretty straight
line and this is a lot easier to see in
retrospect I thought Secretary Clinton
was going to win so this is all with the
benefit of hindsight and a lot of
thought and a lot of talking to a lot of
people and
a lot of places that aren't Chicago and
aren't downtown New York but what I
think this has awakened in people is the
reality that people have to participate
that you know there's this saying you
know that history's decided by the
people that show up there's like nine
different versions of that aphorism that
are largely true in a participatory
democracy right and I think we've gotten
a little lazy and I think President
Trump scares a lot of people in a way
that has been amazing to watch new
people engage in politics and I think
the question to get back to the where
the question started which is okay where
do people begin this is where the
increased access that technology
provides to low barriers to
participation are really really great so
you can start participating in politics
just by being more aware being more
educated being more plugged into what is
actually happening in with leaders with
leadership with campaigns at a level of
just access to that process is so much
greater than it's ever been right but
there's a choice and a desire on our
side that we have to go and seek out
those questions answers to those
questions and then there are so many
ways to start to engage in simple ways
calling congressmen writing letters like
everything from you know five calls to
resist BOTS to you know these are all
progressive oriented things but all of
the same tactics apply for conservatives
but in a lot of what we see with you
know progressives really embracing the
power of being face to face of elected
officials and town halls was something
that the Tea Party used to incredible
effect in the less you know 10 years ago
10 years ago in 2010 midterms in
particular right just post the Obama
election and so these tools themselves
are not particularly partisan but
they've reduced the barrier to
participation sufficiently that it makes
it easier for sort of first-time
activists to get started and what I
would say is that there's one there's a
couple of sort of like lie
the heart of progressive politics that
are super problematic one of them is
that all politics is local
I'll Paulette I would say that when Tip
O'Neill said that in the 80s local was
meant to be an analogue for what matters
most to you the true statement is all
politics is personal matters to you is
what matters to you and that might be
local or it might not be and the thing
that I always say to people is to start
right that don't wait for there is no
magic way to participate we live in a
republic we have to win elections to
gain power we don't live in a direct
democracy so like you know large-scale
open-source policymaking is really is
interesting for as a listening exercise
and for understanding communities and
for surfacing ideas that we haven't
thought of but it's not we don't live in
a direct democracy where open-source
policy actually creates policy directly
so we have to participate in all kinds
of ways I think one of the places where
we need more attention is converting
this kind of this sort of general Eric
resistance participation we see on the
Left right now into political power
right so the in LA in the city elections
back in March fewer people voted then
turned out for the women's March on
inauguration day that's maybe just a
function of the fact that it wasn't a
contested mayoral election and it's sort
of off cycle and not competitive but an
eleven and a half percent voter
participation rate turnout rate should
scare all of us that's that's a problem
right because because we do live in a
republic we do need to believe in the
value of participating in this process
and this is where leadership matters a
lot this is where reclaiming the sort of
joy and optimism and public service
about politics in government is
something that has to be a coherent
priority of the party of our leaders of
people running for office on both sides
or we're going to be in a place where
democracy is the system of faith
and cynicism is extremely dangerous and
long-term corrosive there's been a lot
of talk about the normalization of you
know propaganda and lying and since
President Trump took office and I think
those things are super problematic
because the institutions of the system
matter a lot matter a lot more than the
than the personalities and when
personalities start trumping
institutions no pun intended or
unintended I guess you start leaning
toward autocracy pretty fast
and that's nowhere we want to go the net
neutrality argument usually gets wrapped
around things like you know Netflix and
cable television and sort of cotton sort
of commercial content distribution that
kind of thing I think the place where
net neutrality is particularly important
is around activism writing around
government it you know if companies can
change the way you know they route
packets and prioritize content based on
financial decisions they can also do it
based on ideological decisions and you
start inching your way toward you know
government-run media it's not a long
jump between that question and
government managed suppression of
participation in from insurgent or
counter opinion ideas right that's not a
long leap and I think that I worry less
about the commercial problems because I
think look if Verizon if Netflix has to
pay more for faster pipes they're
figured out like they'll figure out how
to make money they'll figure out how to
get people more episodes of house of
cards it will work out for them they
will make money activists not being able
to use services like Twilio effectively
to call Congress because internet
neutrality has changed the you know the
way that people have access to and for
Meishan is is potentially catastrophic
for people understanding that their
participation is valuable and one of the
things that these tools like I said when
we're thinking about this question of
new activism and giving more access to
more participation if people don't
believe that that participation will
work or it literally won't work now
we're starting to create barriers to
participation and in a participatory
democracy but no barrier to
participation are good whether they're
voting whether it's content whether it's
listening whether it's being able to
hold leaders to account none that limits
on any of those things are bad
[Music]
you